[Музика]
привіт усім, мене звати Анна, я
вчитель англійської мови, просто перегляньте, коли буде
одна ніч, ви повинні заповнити, будь ласка,
швидко
сьогодні ми продовжимо розмову
про англомовні країни, ми
збираємося дізнатися про спорт  у Канаді
та США, тож давайте почнемо так, перш ніж
ми поїдемо в США та Канаду, давайте
подивимося на найкласичніші спори,
які насправді були створені у Великій Британії,
так що, як ви можете побачити на слайді,
Великобританія славиться футболом, який усі
знають  що і на попередньому уроці на
одному з попередніх уроків ми
говорили про футбол, і ми назвали п'ять
найвідоміших футбольних команд в Англії,
тому Британія також славиться регбі,
на дошці ви можете побачити м'яч,
який використовується для літака  регбі регбі
також популярний у всьому світі, особливо
в США, інший вид спорту, яким грають
у Великобританії, і насправді він походить
звідти, це теніс і настільний теніс
або іншими словами пінг-понг інший вид спорту
У Великобританії також грають у
бадмінтон і сквош. Веслування на каное також є
одним із найвідоміших лісів
у Британії. Оксфордські коледжі в Кембриджі
щороку проводять змагання
з веслування на каное, тому студенти цих коледжів сидять на човнах
і веслують.
разом, щоб перевірити, хто найкращий,
і снукер, у який також
грають у Британії, і насправді він був
створений у цій країні, тому тепер ми
наближаємося до наших місць призначення, а
тепер ми збираємося поглянути на
спорт  там грають у США, тож
поїдемо туди США відомі
футболом вони називають це футболом у США
футбол або футбол є дуже важливим
видом спорту в США команди США намагаються
отримати найкращі результати
та найкращі результати, а про бейсбол
усі знають  бейсбол, і всі
знають, що це значний вид спорту
в США на фото ви можете побачити
бейсбол м'яч, який використовується для гри в
бейсбол, вам також знадобиться бита, щоб
вдарити м'яч битою баскетбол один o  f
найвідоміша сила світу також
популярна в США, і хокей у
хокей грають на льоду, вам
знадобляться ковзани, щоб грати в цю гру, і
вам знадобиться хокейна шайба, щоб забити і
покласти її в сітку  команда, тому в
хокей також грають у Канаді, і
насправді сьогодні ми поговоримо
про США та Канаду та спорт, який є
взаємним і дуже важливим для обох цих
країн, ми розпочнемо одразу
зі словникового запасу про  на дошці ви можете
побачити п'ять слів, пов'язаних зі
спортом, праворуч ви можете побачити
визначення, наше завдання збирається
зіставити слова з визначеннями ojen adagiamo
став opioid sleeve equipo que hacen
estamos Porto Bravo Raj was Nagina
нудотний Thomas F Daniel's give not as
Slava panic Nia is mechina, перш за все,
я збираюся прочитати вголос ці п'ять слів,
ви можете повторити за мною, потім ми
будемо відповідати словам з
визначеннями, тож давайте почнемо з
першого в дверях у дверях номер два
рішення  рішення номер три зберігати
для зберігання номер чотири прибити до цвяха і
номер п'ять обладнання обладнання
праворуч у нас є визначення давайте
подивимося на них a щоб закріпити або закріпити
щось цвяхом бути необхідні
предмети для певної мети див.
засіб розв’язування задачі D, що проводиться,
використовується в будівлі та II, щоб зберегти
щось для майбутнього використання, тому давайте почнемо
з першого слова indoor і
спробуємо узгодити його з деякими визначеннями
з одним із визначень, звичайно,
і коли ми візьмемо  подивіться на слово «
закритий», ми розуміємо, що ми говоримо про
щось, що відбувається всередині.
be D проводиться або використовується
в будівлі, давайте подивимося на
рішення другого слова, ми зазвичай використовуємо
форму цього слова дієслова форму цього
слова, щоб вирішити, коли ми говоримо ab
вирішуючи якусь проблему, коли нам потрібно
розв’язати проблему, нам потрібно знайти її
рішення,
щоб визначення, якому ми будемо відповідати,
було б C, а засоби розв’язування
задачі, тож метод, який ми використовуємо для
вирішення проблеми,
наступне слово для збереження тут  на
малюнку ви можете побачити сховище, яке
насправді є місцем, де зберігаються речі,
тому ми говоримо про місце, можливо,
всередині будівлі, і
визначення, яке буде відповідати тут, буде
e зберігати щось для майбутнього використання
наступне слово to  Прибити малюнок
насправді допоможе вам здогадатися,
що це означає, і так, ми говоримо
про те, щоб щось відремонтувати або виправити
щось цвяхом і молотком,
так що два цвяха - це закріпити або закріпити
щось цвяхом dr.  Роберта показує,
що Pomo who zurafa це було б
визначенням а і останнє слово тут слово
номер п’ять обладнання обладнання — це
набір посуду, який нам потрібен для виконання певної
діяльності, тож у нас залишилося останнє визначення,
тобто визначення B, тож необхідні
предмети для певної діяльності.  Мета зараз, коли
ми вивчили ці слова, ми можемо перейти
до тексту, ми збираємося прочитати текст
про дуже відомий вид спорту, в який грають у
всьому світі. Цей вид спорту має
походження з двох країн, у яких народилася людина, яка
винайшла цей вид спорту  Канада
і коли ця людина винайшла вид спорту, який
він жив у США, тож давайте поглянемо
на екран і прочитаємо текст прочитайте
текст історію про баскетбол, який
найпопулярніший вид спорту у світі,
відповідь, звичайно, футбол чи футбол,
але  а як щодо найпопулярнішого
виду спорту в закритих приміщеннях, відповідь на це питання полягає в тому, що
баскетбольний баскетбол винайшов
Канадієнс для свого вчителя д-ра.  Джеймс
Нейсміт у 1891 р.  Нейсміт
працював у коледжі в Массачусетсі
в США, і він хотів знайти спосіб
нагодувати студентів під час зимового
баскетболу. Його рішенням студенти
грали в перші ігри зі справжніми
кошиками, старими, які використовувалися для
зберігання персиків і кошиків.  були прибиті
до стіни по одному на кожному кінці спортзалу
з роками дизайн кошика
змінив баскетбол популярність
швидко зростала не вимагало
дорогого обладнання та спеціалізованого
одягу Національна баскетбольна
асоціація НБА була створена в 1948 році вона
базується в США  і є однією з
найуспішніших професійних спортивних ліг
у світі, яка починалася як гра,
спеціально розроблена для невеликої групи
чоловіків у Спрінгфілді, переросла в один
із найпопулярніших видів спорту в світі,
коли ми прочитали текст про
баскетбол і  як це було винайдено, давайте
перевіримо ваше розуміння цього тексту,
наше завдання — вирішити,
правдива інформація на слайді чи
неправда t  подивіться на речення давайте
почнемо з першого білі
епендимоми на червоному Shinya the Akiane
dorsey у націоналістах dye names один
рік без обдуреної Шивани, але davis
він не для Matsu texty
вона ніколи не David, звичайно, якщо ми маємо
повні речення, які нам потрібні, щоб виправити
їх, ви показали нам, що у вас блювота, і
проблема була у піхви Будди, коли ви були
проблемою, тож давайте подивимося на
перше, що баскетбол є єдиним великим
видом спорту, який був винайдений комітетом.
текст був
це комітет, який створив баскетбол
насправді немає, це була лише одна людина, доктор.
Джейн Нейсміт, тож це речення хибне,
тут ви можете побачити фотографію доктора.  Джейн
Сміт, яка насправді створила
баскетбольну гру номер два Джеймс Нейсміт був
американцем, який жив і працював у
Спрінгфілді, Манітоба, чи це правда,
чи ви точно пам'ятаєте, де він жив
і працював на початку тексту,
перш ніж ми почали його читати, я сказав вам,
що
Джейн Нейсміт народилася в Канаді, і він
працював в Америці, тому Спрінг відчував, що він
американець, це правда,
тому він не був американцем, він був
канадцем, чи жив у Спрінгфілді, так
, але насправді Спрінгфілд
розташований не в Манітобі, як Манітоба
це провінція Канади Спрінгфілд
розташовано в штаті Массачусетс США цей
факт неправдивий тут ви можете побачити
ознаку Спрінгфілда, штат Массачусетс
номер три, НБА почалася в 1960 році як
абсолютно нова ліга, це правда, чи
це було саме тут, коли НБА почалася
насправді не  цей факт неправдивий.
Ліга НБА розпочалася в 1948 році під номером чотири,
вони відразу використовували сітки,
оскільки була винайдена гра, це те, що справжні
шахи Бренда Ваккаро Стовалл а  автобусний
конвой nice it K od Rizzo sitka о
круто надійний кабель буде переважаючий JM
Nesmith йому новий надіслати проблему
відповідно до тексту вони не
використовували сітчасті кошики вони насправді
використовували дерев'яні кошики, а сітки
з'явилися пізніше номер п'ять ні
Для гри в баскетбол потрібні спеціальні предмети, чи потрібен
вам
спеціальний одяг для гри в баскетбол,
шорти та футболка були б досить гарним
дорогим спорядженням, вам просто потрібен
горіх і баскетбольний м'яч, тож цей факт
вірний, вам нічого не потрібно  додаткове обладнання
для гри в цей тип гри, тому в
тексті ми дізналися про
баскетбол і ми дізналися
історію його створення, а тепер давайте подивимося на
деякі граматичні вправи на попередніх
уроках, про які ми говорили про минуле
просте та минуле  безперервні часи тепер
наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб переглянути їх і
порівняти pa past simple і past
Continuous past simple з past continue, яка
б різниця у використанні цих
часів, давайте та  ке подивіться ось швидке
нагадування Невіл, кожен Кандагар робить
правильний простий перехід, продовжує незайманий
скринь Манолі
da da da Giovanni Muno, у цьому
реченні є два дієслова давайте
поглянемо я дивився телевізор, коли він
прибув, хм, так що дивлюся
підкреслено, і, як ви бачите, він показує
нам довгу дію
в минулому, коли він прибув, це
підкреслене дієслово показує нам коротку дію,
яка щойно відбулася в минулому, і
це так минуло безперервно для довгих
дій past simple для коротких дій
Я сподіваюся, що  ви пам’ятаєте це, і
лише швидке нагадування про допоміжне дієслово,
яке ми використовували, щоб зробити минуле безперервним,
ми маємо дієслово to be у двох формах was
і дієслово then ми використовуємо дієслово із
закінченням ing, коли говоримо про past
simple it is  важливо пам’ятати, що
в позитивних реченнях ми ставимо дієслово
в просту форму другого минулого, якщо
це заперечне речення, нам знадобиться
допоміжне речення didnt, якщо ми ставимо
запитання, нам потрібно буде pu  t did до
початку речення, тоді у нас є
підмет, а потім у нас є основна
форма дієслова, тож давайте перейдемо до практики, щоб
на дошці ми могли побачити історію, яку нам
потрібно завершити, у нас є слова в
дужках, які мають  щоб бути відкритим,
подивіться на дошку, і тут ви
побачите текст, у якому нашим завданням є
розкрити дужки, використовуючи дієслова в
минулому простому або минулому тривалому, тому ми
повинні завершити розповідь
правильним минулим часом  дієслова в
дужках минулого простого або тривалого минулого
давайте подивимося на текст і
почнемо працювати з ним.
Іноді я ненавиджу комп'ютери одного разу, коли я
намагаюся виконати домашнє завдання з англійської мови на
ноутбуці, батарея розрядилася, тож
у цьому реченні ми маємо дві дії  одна
дія довга одна дія коротка, тож
коли я намагаюся зробити свою англійську
те, що людина намагається для газону,
ймовірно, це була не просто коротка дія,
тому тут, у цьому проміжку, нам знадобиться, що
минуле продовжує використовуватися у другому
розрив нам знадобиться t  o використовуйте коротку дію
в минулому просто, тож давайте подивимося
один раз, коли я намагався виконати
домашнє завдання з англійської на своєму ноутбуці, батарея розрядилася.
Я лежу на ліжку й
слухав музику на Spotify, тож тут у нас є два
одночасно  дії, коли людина
слухала музику на Spotify та
іншу дію, яка насправді була
ідеєю безперервної аудиторії від Морозіні -
прадо Джованна V відд macchesney gek
продюсер Valley Spray Джон
Паноццо Маноло мояма моя мати шотландська К. минуле
безперервно я лежав на своєму ліжку і я
слухав музику, це допомагає
мені зосередитися.
Я також спілкуюся зі своїм другом Даніелом у
Facebook знову ми говоримо про
безперервну дію в минулому,
ймовірно, людина спілкувалася досить
довго зі своїм другом, тому ми скажемо,
що я був  також спілкуюся зі своїм другом у
Facebook, давайте перейдемо до наступного абзацу
добре, щоб я не зосереджувався
на домашньому завданні й забув підключити свій
ноутбук О gia Nash після того, як Касія поголена
шию на Cen  Трал Парк сказав, що так само,
як і болото біля Абуті, це той хлопець, що в
кабінці не було дверей для ноутбука
, тому він не міг зарядити свій
ноутбук, ми можемо передбачити, що ноутбук
згасне, але перш ніж дістатися до цієї
частини  історія, давайте
ще раз подивимося на проміжок,
щоб я не зосереджувався, як правило, вам потрібно
зосередитися протягом тривалого часу, щоб виконати
домашнє завдання, тому тут ми будемо використовувати
минуле безперервне.
Я не дуже концентрувався на своєму
домашньому завданні і забув чому  забув, чому
минуло просто, тому що це коротка минула
дія. Я не помітив, що
батарея розрядилася. Я якраз завершував
твір, коли екран став
чорним, тож раз екран почорнів
на тривалий час або це сталося в один
момент  ми говоримо про довгу
дію чи просто закінчену дію
коротку так, звичайно, ми говоримо
про коротку дію тут, тому ми
будемо використовувати дієслово go у формі минулого
простого часу, щоб минулий зразок
дієслова  йти це пішов так  речення
звучатиме так. Я щойно
закінчував твір, коли екран став
чорним, я знову втрачаю все, що
безперервна дія ми говоримо про
щось, що відбувалося протягом тривалого
часу
ні ноутбук вимкнувся ноутбук
більше не працював  тому людина втратила
все відразу в одну мить, тому тут
ми будемо використовувати past simple past
simple of Toulouse is lost, так що я втратив
все наступне речення я кричу від
розчарування, тому людина кричала
про Лона,
ймовірно, тут ми говоримо про
короткий  кричати, тож тут нам знадобиться
минула форма дієслова to scream, а щоб
зробити це, нам знадобиться закінчення Edie
scream – це звичайне дієслово, тому
ми додамо Edie і тут, щоб це
речення звучало так, як я кричав від
розчарування.  тато забіг до моєї
спальні, тож тато забігав у
спальню надовго, чи це була лише
коротка дія, так, звичайно, це була
коротка дія, він просто забіг у
спальню, тому мій тато прибіг я  У моїй
спальні пам’ятайте, що прийти – це
неправильне дієслово, і тут нам потрібна його
проста форма минулого, тому що прийшло, я
майже плачу, тому він дав мені свій ноутбук, тож
які
шанси на ці дві дії, у нас є
дві дії та одна  з них довга
інша одна сорочка, коли вона взяла
Мохаммеда вінджі дивність нове виробництво
хочу бути в шоці еротика давайте подивимось
крик би був, що коротка дія ні
насправді ми говоримо про довгу
, а як щодо дати так що дати
ноутбук це, ймовірно,  коротка дія, тому
для першого ми будемо використовувати минуле
безперервне я майже плакала, тому він мій
батько дав мені свій ноутбук наступне речення
я намагаюся згадати все в своєму есе
так проблеми її тато нав'язлива любов моя
mo SM але я не міг  так чи була людина, яка
намагалася lon ні, ймовірно, людина
відкрила ноутбук почав писати і
нічого не зміг згадати для цієї
дії ми будемо використовувати past simple я
намагався запам'ятати все це було
досить важко, особливо тому що  тому що
Деніел надсилав мені багато кумедних
відео, тому, як ви можете бачити в другій
частині речення, ми також використовуємо
просту форму дієслова в минулому, це було так
чи інакше, поки я дивився,
Wi-Fi перестав працювати в кінці це було
мабуть, краще, тому що мені вдалося
закінчити есе, тому людині
вдалося закінчити есе, або
людині просто вдалося закінчити есе,
тому завершення есе було б довгою
дією або просто короткою одноразовою дією,
тому наш вибір має перейти до  коротка
дія в минулому для цього розриву ми
виберемо просту форму минулого, якою
можна керувати управляти, є звичайним дієсловом, і для
нього потрібне закінчення ET. Пам’ятайте, що якщо
дієслово закінчується на букву e, виділяється одна буква e
, нам не потрібно  використовуйте подвійне
e, щоб один з них був забраний,
в кінці слова буде просто GED,
тому я сподіваюся, що в цій вправі все зрозуміло з
минулим простим проти минулого безперервного,
тому сьогодні ми дізналися
про походження баскетболу
людиною, яка створила  він народився в Канаді,
і він жив в Америці, коли він
насправді добре створив спорт, також
ми поглянули на різницю
між минулим простим і минулим тривалим
часами те, що ми дізналися,
past simple використовується для коротких дій,
які відбувалися в минулому  past
continious використовується для тривалих дій, які
відбувалися протягом тривалого періоду часу
в минулому або в певний момент,
тому на сьогодні все, дуже дякую
за увагу до наступного разу
[Музика]
ви